walker wearing number
99 that's ninth for the mets this
evening
yeah look at that last line there
opponents average down at 166.
he's become a better pitcher as he gets
older and i say that because he's got a
better pitch mix you'll see more sinkers
than he's thrown in the past still has
the real good four seamer
but sinker sliders split changes very
compact easy delivery
and after being down 02 acuna runs it
full
payoff speaking of which smokes that
ball past the second base bag
ocuna aboard to start the night 2-2
and freeman chased it high fastball
which walker likes
gets the strikeout for the first down to
the first great execution on walker's
part
now walker kicks and deals swinging a
foul into the middle of nino strength
three
side retired caught up with a fastball
no runs no hit or one hit
and thrown out stealing nobody left
middle of the first
it's the braves nothing in the mix
coming up they'll face the
23-year-old new york native from rexford
up in saratoga county that is ian
anderson
i'm one of the best change-ups in the
game his channel is one of the best
pitches in the game not afraid to throw
in fact
full counts as change-up use goes up
that tells you how much confidence he
has in that pitch
the r goes down on strikes anderson with
the k to start his night
well that'll bring up francisco lindor
and it's been fairly well documented the
career low numbers
185 so far this year contreras calls for
it
and it's delivered at the knees for cold
strike three
now he'll face james mccann who has had
to convert to first base
this week the 2-1 pitch lifted in the
air to right field that's deep pacu
going back at the track
at the wall it's gone a home run james
mccann
hits one right to the corner of the
honda clubhouse adjacent to the mets
bullpen
for mccann his third home run of the
year the mets are leading by a score of
one to nothing
well because he gets so many ground ball
outs ian anderson does not give up many
homers he's only allowed
one in his last seven starts but james
mccann
goes where he typically likes to go with
his power to the opposite field with
seven
of the 10 home runs that austin reilly
has hit this year have come
in the last nine games
and he ropes one into left field for a
base head he's got him set up to use
that sinker in if he wants
[Applause]
some sparkling defense at the corners in
this game between
atlanta and new york he robs william
contreras what would have been extra
bases
and maybe even an rbi runners can move
on this 3-2
walker squaring to punt and he takes the
walk
and the bases are loaded and back to the
top of the order for the mets
3-1 to vr and a drive to right field
acuna back at the track and he's got
it metz leave him loaded
anderson gets out after a loud vr
out to the warning tracks ian and the
braves dodged a huge bullet that was a
fastball right down the middle of the
plate
without nobody on third inning
one-nothing the mitts have the lead
walker's downhill the pitch
on the outside corner strike three
called a breaking ball again
and walker posts a one two three inning
his first of the night
anderson's 01. mccann it's a line drive
towards center chasing heredia back
still going reaching up
it's off his glove it falls in behind
him and rolls toward the fence in center
field
mccann gets to second now he's on his
way to third relay throw from swanson
won't be made
mccann slides into third base safely
we'll see if that's rule to triple
if it is well mccann's got the two hard
parts of the cycle done it would be a
home run in his first hit bat and a
triple here
off the glove of guillermo heredia
that's a ball that clearly should have
been caught by herredia
and i think mccann was quite content to
stop at second base
they're calling it it's kind of like you
know splitting the baby here
they're calling it a double and an error
that ball's got to be caught i'm sorry
that's leading one nothing trying to add
on on this 2-2
back up the middle past the diving
swanson it's two-nothing new york
dom smith with the rbi dominic smith
with the infield and just reached out
and tapped the ball up the middle
swanson with a step to his right lunged
after it with a dive
but he couldn't quite reach it austin
reilly bats now with three and fielders
on the left albie's at first
0-2 ground ball up the middle behind
second peraza's got it steps on second
throw to first
double play to win the inning cameron
mabin will be the batter
he is one out away here
from a mets record and he does not want
the longest hit list streak to begin
amit's career
oh for 26 mabin has tied charlie smith
0-1 maybe lines 1 toward right it moves
acuna toward the corner to his left
making the catch at his left hip to
retire cameron mavin so there's over 27
and a new men's record for
the longest hitler streak to begin a
men's career well they won't give him
the baseball for that
but some day some year somebody will ask
the question and cameron maben will be
the answer until somebody else comes
along
hey adrian says the left fielder tonight
struck out his first time
waving a miss for adrianza
in boston with a homer in there strike
three called side retired he got him
with a fastball
walker gently pounds his fist the
halfway point tonight jonathan vr is at
the top of the mets order to lead it off
in the home half of the fifth against
ian anderson
vr cranks one deep to center radio
racing back
at the wall and towards the apple
three-nothing mets a charge from vr vr
missed a grand slam earlier to right he
did not miss to dead center
this was a no doubter 93 right down the
middle
and nukem will try to stop the bleeding
here in the bottom of the fifth inning
on the ground good scoop from third by
riley they'll get the force out at
second base
but the run scores and it's four to
nothing mets lindor across
so that runner is still at third for
freeman now castro if he wants could
throw that change up
three 3-2 way inside it gets away from
needle
and atlanta will score its first run on
the wild pitch one down for cameron
maven still seeking that
elusive first new york met hit the 1-0
on the way nub
slowly third base line if it stays fair
it's a hit they're letting it roll
letting it roll it's going to stop it's
a fair ball right next to third base
cameron maben has his first mets hit
after
o for 27 and he's getting a standing
ovation
from the crowd and now brandon drury
will bat for miguel
castro undergoes drury swings and sends
one to
deep left field high and
god a pinch hit two-run blast the third
mets home run of the night it's six to
one
oh and won the count now the pitch
ground ball shortstop hole
swanson slides can't get it it's under
his glove and into left field
they are racist around the score it's
7-1 mets
lendores fired up at third as mccann
delivers again
jay flaw is on runners at the corners
here is nito who was struck out twice
a little ground ball in the left field
off the bat of neato
kenny said it he's been hitting and he
drives in another
a four-run sixth inning and eight to one
men's lead
billy mckinney will be the ninth man to
bat in the inning and eight runs matches
the mets season high
hammered to right billy mckinney
keeps on adding for the mets with an
upper deck
shot his first mets home run
and it is 11-1 new york there's a little
of that power
they told us about from billy mckinney
well 11 runs a season high and four home
runs in this game for the mints
a season high 1-1 breaking ball hit up
the middle tovar to his left snags it
then slips from his knees
chucks it to first mccann digs it out
and contreras is out
to win the inning will tovar slipped on
the outfield grass
after snagging that hard hit ball off
the bat of contreras
and from his knees he just threw it as
hard as he could now lindor will bat
with two outs
lindor hits one in the air right center
fairly well back goes acuna
that balls deep and it's gone home run
francisco lindor
well he needed it anyway he could get it
and no matter the score
it has to feel good for lindor as the
mets lead
13-1 barnes ready now the pit
payoff to contreras got him swinging
one of the best performances and wins
for the new york mets this season
they've won now four in a row they're
five over 500
and they maintain the lead at the top of
the
nl east